SPEAKER: Today we're
talking about Apigee
X, underwater cables
and Cloud DNS Peering.
Welcome to "This Week in
Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
APIs are the backbone of
digital transformation.
And to help
organizations navigate
today's very
challenging landscape,
we're announcing Apigee X.
A major release of our API
management platform,
Apigee X seamlessly
weaves together Google
Cloud's expertise
in AI, security and
networking, to help enterprises
efficiently manage the assets
on which digital transformation
initiatives are built.
We're thrilled to say bonjour
to the Dunant submarine cable
system, named after
Henry Dunant, which
has been deployed and tested,
and is now ready for service.
Dunant features a
new design, and will
deliver record-breaking capacity
of 250 terabytes per second
across the large and vast ocean.
This is enough to transmit
the entire digitized Library
of Congress three
times every second.
We're committed to building
an excellent network
with well-provisioned direct
paths between our Cloud
and our customers.
Take a look at this
blog for more info.
Sometimes the application teams
want to manage their own DNS
records.
There's a solution to support
fine-grained IAM policies
using Cloud DNS Peering.
In this article, we
explore how to use
it to give your application
teams autonomy over their DNS
records, while ensuring
that the central networking
team maintains granular control
over the entire environment.
Machine Learning, or ML, can
help you solve hard business
problems in new ways.
But getting started
can feel overwhelming.
We're fortunate to have some
great leaders in Google Cloud
AI who have decades
of experience,
and want to share some
advice for getting
started from their learnings.
Check out the blog for some
videos from our experts.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
Thank you for being here.
We'll see you in the Cloud.
Cheers.